we are risking our lives to bring your
loved one home aviators are going out
every day as essential workers taking
you to and from your destinations
Kovach 19 continues to pummel the
airline industry and people are urged to
stay home and not travel airline workers
around the world are feeling uncertain
both for the security of their jobs and
for their own health in my six year
history of being with in aviation and
work with two different airlines I have
never seen such widespread suspension of
services most of my co-workers they are
concerned about their upcoming salary
and everything if they are not going to
fly Airlines around the world have had
to adapt to new restrictions on where
they can fly and many are not flying at
all I have been monitoring this entire
spread of coded 19 since it was
impacting the Asian carriers and like
what we saw with the Asian carriers we
saw heavy furloughs heavy unpaid leaves
and then in the worst of the instances
the closure of some airlines so that was
just the natural matriculation of what
happened in the Asian market now they
are going to give me other flights and
maybe I'm not going to get more flights
because now we have a whole lot of crew
available they cannot accommodate
everyone so most of them will be on
standby and most of them will be flying
so it depends what is going to happen
next
I absolutely 1000% believe that we're
gonna have airlines that survive they're
just gonna cut their losses shrink a
little bit you know maybe have some
unpaid leaves here there but they're
gonna be able to manage and push through
and then I also know that there's going
to be the airlines who unfortunately
this is gonna be the straw that broke
the camel's back and they're going to
have to close the doors I know things
are gonna get a little bit difficult for
a little bit but I do do hold firm that
we're going to bounce back relief is
coming though at least for US airlines
as a part of the coronavirus aid relief
and Economic Security Act airlines will
receive nearly 60 billion in financial
assistance
on the condition that they will not
furlough or layoff employees
until September 30th airlines have also
adopted new policies to help reduce the
spread of the kovat 19 virus all flight
attendants are wearing gloves and masks
because this is the procedure now we do
have to follow it on every flight we
have to even if we find in any on any
flight any passenger we who is coughing
all right
he/she is feeling unwell we do provide
them with masks and gloves we also
provide them sanitizers and stuff like
that to wear that mask like four
consecutive eight hours and four if we
are flying to Toronto for like
consecutive 14 hours on your weights
it's quite tough one of the things that
we see system-wide and across the
industry is the allowing of wearing
facial masks as well as hand gloves this
is something that historically
traditionally would have been frowned
upon but giving the lighting light of
the circumstances and just not knowing
how the virus is transmitted all the way
we want to take those extra precautions
we have to take care of ourselves
because only this is the only way we are
keeping our families safe as well
because at the end of the day we are
coming back to our family right
I see all airlines across the board not
taking this lightly because in our
industry alone we have to have a hyper
sense of cleanliness just because it's
confined quarters recirculated air all
those things so you want to make sure
it's as clean as possible making sure
that we have filters are born making
sure that the airplanes are getting
clean thoroughly on a regular basis if
not every shift so I think industry-wide
we're seeing all airlines taking
sanitation of the aircraft and of the
most frequented like touched places very
seriously deep cleaning of the aircraft
that is very necessary everything they
clean it so well and they provide with
hand sanitizers on board and the gloves
the mask and everything like that I
flown a few different airlines and I
have seen some airlines offer clothes
water bottles with the snacks at their
service their modified service I've had
one airline that gave you a water bottle
and a snack and they issued that as I
boarded which was interesting
I am very stressed right now honestly I
am I wasn't able to sleep last night
properly because I was extremely
stressed what if I'm going to catch this
virus what is going to happen I find
that the people that the aviators who
were here for 9/11 or maybe the
bankruptcy of 2008 they seem to be more
along those lines they're level-headed
they're just kind of like you know we've
been through this before
we understand that aviation is cyclical
so we're just you know we're gonna take
it a day at a time and then don't worry
we're gonna bounce back when I woke up
in the morning I told my mother that
he'd stay away from me since she's a
diabetic and she's 50 above so even
though I have a separate room but still
I told her not to hug me not to come in
my room nothing is certain right now
so I am stressed definitely stressed
very much right now
aviators are going out every day as
essential workers taking you to and from
your destination we are risking our
lives to bring your loved one home we
cannot stay at home it's not that easy
it's most of the people they only think
we are only you know having fun and it's
full of glamour and fun and party and
that is it it's not we want to encourage
you guys to practice social distancing
and also don't fly if you don't need to
if you feel sick if you don't feel if
you feel like you're up - even if it's
just a little clam you stay home because
aviation professionals are the ones
taking me to and fro and you're
increasing their risk of transmitting
this disease all over the world as a
direct response to the impact that koban
19 is having on the aviation community
critics has launched an aviation relief
fund and this fund will raise money to
go directly to frontline employees who
have been adversely financially impacted
by this virus
[Music]
you